oh i used to talk to will chamberlain on
the phone i bet
chamberlain at a basketball game my
mother wanted his autograph so we got
him as he was coming out and
he we exchanged phone numbers and he
wanted me to come over his house but i
never quite got there
and we but he we would talk on the phone
he would call me in fact the one
time before the playoffs it was between
the knicks
and the 40 i don't know i can't remember
76 years or something
the box and the knicks and they were
playing off to see who the lakers were
going to play and i was talking to
ultimate the whole time it was really
it was interesting it was fun i enjoyed
it
i never became one of his hundred women
no he says he had
a hundred women i was not one of them
100
first probably i was not i think people
picture me as this i don't know lonely
old [ __ ]
i could say quiet oh girl
they that puts your life in cole's life
and it
inserts myself into your life i think
that
people never realized well they didn't
really
realize that i i had a life before you
yes
she did have it left before me yeah and
it was the 60s and 70s which is a
fantastic time i think to
to be a young lady to grow up in
so yeah i i glad people realized that
um i'm a lot of fun i have a good time i
know how to
go out and have fun i still do i
definitely i learned my ways from
from somewhere from somebody the apple
doesn't fall very far from the tree
well congrats cole and miss debbie you
made it to the love games finale
i know you two are really close let me
give you guys a round of applause
i know you are close already but what
has this experience done for your
relationship
you know it's it's been very uh i don't
know it's definitely
expanding our relationship you know be
because it happened you know during
quarantine on
lockdown we self shot the show so
not only we have to do that aspect
setting the other show up to film but we
also have to
film it and some of the questions are
kind of yeah they weren't fake
yeah and you're right they tried the
best
you tried the best but you made it you
made it pretty far
and i know a lot of people are saying is
it fair that debbie
you know you've known colt all his life
is it fair for you to compete against
other couples what are your thoughts on
that
i think people really didn't think much
of us probably
thought we'd fail early on you know
they're not a couple blah blah blah
and we really surprised a lot of people
and now they're complaining about it so
whatever yeah
yeah i don't think that people i don't
know that
parents know that much about their
children they really
say they do but i but since we live
together
so we may have a little bit of a benefit
how long do you think that um this
living situation is gonna last is this
something you just
are cool with for a while now or
what will it take for you to actually
move out
oh at this point i feel like everyone's
doing it you know
the way it goes i'm doing it i'm here
yeah i'm ahead of the curve a little bit
honestly i feel like
but uh you know at this point in my life
my mother's born in life i don't feel
like there's a
i mean if she wants to move out i'm not
gonna stop her obviously but
you know ideal situation we all kind of
live while like you live like next door
yeah that would be terrific yeah you
know until we can make that dream a
reality we'll
do the best that we can what couple
would you say has been your
your toughest competition oh toughest
competition
so far at least so far you say larissa
i think we underestimated them a little
bit also she knows this
yeah that she does know a lot yeah so so
that that definitely helped them a lot
when it came to
that answering questions about us yeah
yeah
well let's talk about that moment
because before the competition even
started things got heated between you
and larissa stormed off of the set
my question for you for you cole and
debbie
is why do you why do you think that
there's still so much
bad blood there to a point where
you you all can't even really have a
conversation without things getting
heated
why do you think that i don't think
there was ever closure
so they left a lot of ends open
yeah yeah because they need to tie them
up
never really had a resolution as such
but
you know time is pretty much ended or
whatever we
had but i don't know i think it's just
the sudden appearance
you know of each other randomly out of
nowhere just kind of
well like spark up old stuff actually at
the end of the round that we played with
larissa and eric
there was good vibrations yeah we had we
ended it
very friendly very nice and i think you
did a lot for your relationship
to be competing against her it worked
out well
definitely by the end we're all kind of
we're getting along and having fun
so yeah it was definitely progress yeah
and call
that leads to my next question for you
did it bring up any feelings competing
with larissa and her new boyfriend
did that make you feel any type of way
uh i felt kind of more
competitive a little bit i don't know
why i don't know if this was like
i kind of wanted them to not do as well
like oh i would have done better
you know yeah but i know i i don't i
don't it didn't really bring them too
much you know it was kind of a surprise
honestly
but it was definitely fun let me tell
you absolutely well we've seen your
dating life play out on the single life
it has been enjoyable to watch i must
say
[Laughter]
and vanessa it seems like she's coming
around
slowly but surely but what did you tell
us about
that colt you told her you were in love
with her
where do things stand now uh you know i
love vanessa you know she's a
part of my life she's my best friend you
know
and we'll see what happens with that you
just have to watch the
the single life well debbie do you think
that you
are hindering colt's dating life at all
or or no
i know i don't think so no i pretty much
leave him alone i don't get involved i
um really the only thing that i ask is
if he's not going to come home at night
let me know
she still worries about me i do you know
but that's with anybody if you have any
kind of a roommate you
you'd want to know if they weren't
coming home because if you hear somebody
you know downstairs it's just the right
thing to do
sure but i don't get involved with his
uh dating or ask questions or
well she's been very useful uh fountain
of wisdom you know i
don't have the best track record in the
past dating unfortunately well i'm
curious because we hear a lot about
colt's dating life debbie but we don't
hear that much about
yours is there anyone special
no special oh no not really
i'm i'm putting myself out there i'm
just trying right now
putting yourself out there in brave new
world and all that
but yes so yeah getting back on the
market
i am would that ever be something you
would allow to be filmed
and invite them to literally i would do
that
yeah sure yeah yeah well if you hear an
out there production
debbie that i think that that would be
good for a lot of women
though who feel like you know they'd
they lost their groove or whatever just
to see someone else out there
getting back into the world that would
be inspirational it's been a very long
time it's different right yeah i mean
to lose your way the world changes the
way you date changes i was married for
27 years to his dad and then his dad had
passed away 13 years ago so it's been a
it's been a while since i've been but
the hiatus
so yeah i'm looking forward to maybe
enjoying some company
90 day franchise we need to make that
happen i mean the universe is already so
big the 90 day universe is huge why not
throw
miss debbie out there dating absolutely
i'd be willing to do that
we just have to find the right guy why
are you two keeping up with the current
season of 90 day fiance
i am yeah okay if you had a couple
or anyone on the show right now that you
would love to give a piece of advice
to who would it be
who do you have to like me oh okay
brandon
and julia okay get the heck away from
baby oh my god back off get a hobby and
people used to tell me that but
it's totally different circumstances i i
never
involved myself when you and larissa
were here
i never told you couldn't be in the same
room i never tried to
say oh it's gonna be four of us not
going out to dinner i never said that
i gave you guys all the space she needed
um
i just would tell her to back off and
let them live their life
i know that sounds strange really
strange for me but it's totally
different circumstances
yeah i see it perfectly clearly what she
says that she did
okay i like
you